folks Chris waters here hosting on the
live stage show at gamespot 2014's
coverage of e3 I'm super excited to be
closing out the show here and we're
closing it out in a really colorful way
with the last tinker is something
something something these guys are gonna
tell me what it is it's dominic and Moe
from me me me productions guys welcome
to the stage hey ah so first things
first the last tinker video of colors
city of colors I even asked you that
before the show ok good get is a heart
Idol ok so the last ticker city of
colors one look at this game and you
understand where the city of colors
parts come from this is a very vibrant
very uh you know saturated kind of
environment what kind of what what are
you guys going for with this art is that
what you guys you know where do our
inspiration come from for this all right
there to things like we look at some
artists that we really like like
hundertwasser he's like an austrian
artists and nicky d's on file which is a
from italy i think ah there some very
nice other stairs like those like
colorful things vibrance with very
smooth forms and stuff mm-hmm and we
really want you to have like something
that is not like crazy or not like my
thing wants to bring back colors and
have yeah very nice and look at where
you like just feel good when you watch
it and you're enjoying it so far it's
working I feel good I liked that
especially those cacti before and these
doors here kind of have that corrugated
cardboard look to them so it you know in
terms of that sort of design it makes it
it gives us this crafted feel ya that
exactly is one very big fitting in the
game because all the people are artists
and curators so they would build the
world themselves they all did it by
their own hands that's why it's
handcrafted
nice I someone hand crafted these rails
apparently for riding along yeah and
this little slow-mo action try to re
trying to grab a cup of coffee there no
this is the green color spirit aha he's
the embodiment of the green color which
is also taught it to the emotion fear so
he's a super bright guy and he's not
with you and he's the whole time like I
don't do that that's way too exciting it
we got to stop you and but you just want
to push him that he liked overcomes his
fears and that he's like a good normal
again in this hat but right now he's
just like ah he's freaking out a little
bit alright so tell me about the sort of
the premise here because there you have
this this character yeah green color
spirit that's am I very trepidatious who
is the player character its core ooh
he's the lost tinker he's a kind of
monkish looking guy he's this adventure
Todd he's very good at crafting stuff
mm-hmm and he has this like special
talent that he can learn the power of
the colors and with that you can
influence people's behavior alright and
so learning or learning the power of
colors what does that mean for the
player what kind of things do the power
of colors enabled you to do yeah for
some of the green color that we will
acquire here that we already acquired
for him is tied to the emotion fear so
you can make people afraid for example
as an enemy I can paint them green and
then you're like runs off it's terrible
that she falls down and dies have some
cool stuff so there's some combat which
we'll see in everybody in a second but
there's also platforming yeah there's
exploring through the environment and
there's getting totally shredded by that
gear a few times Tom oh yeah I think I'm
back yeah no it's good to see I mean you
know we don't want to be a total
cakewalk but so you know adventuring
through doing some platforming I you
guys sort of diversity finding the
gameplay experience in that way between
combat and sort of chatting with folks
yeah so we platform in combat and
puzzles we have a lot of puzzles and we
have some like really weird stuff for
example there's a music level in the
game Oh
and conduct an orchestra with the colors
really yeah there's some crazy stuff so
we really try to have like very diverse
and always give the player something
like very nice new to experience that
sounds neat all right here we can enjoy
all that comet so rep just feels basic
damage but green makes them afraid so he
runs off now and he would look at the
other way there's like a Ledge you can
make them run oh oh and just go ahead
and just run right off the last one well
yeah I saw that so you used the
environment in a clever way you can make
come but very easy for you it's just
sending them running away I really like
that so all right so is the are the
different color attacks mapped to
different buttons on the controller and
we're playing with the PlayStation pork
is a PlayStation 4 game are that we're
playing on that's the platform you're
playing on curtain currently are you
also targeting release on other
platforms actually we have a scheme
version running right now it's out
already oh it's up already yeah very
cool so people can play the last tinker
city of colors on steam yeah and then
you're coming to PlayStation 4 yes and
we guess to the other consoles as well
hey everywhere every other little place
helps you guys right yes now this
there's the enemies were white and
colorless and now you have this sort of
undulating blob of colorless area is
what is that what does that mean what is
that all that's the thing called the
bleakness it's this white force that
sucks out the colors of the world it
even like tries to destroy the world
completely photos meet that's rude yeah
but the thing is it's not about them
just defeating like the bleak super boss
or something it's more about inspired
people to work together again so because
this power only comes because of the
lack of creativity right now in the
world
mm-hmm and so is this one of the one of
the felt people you're trying to help
inspire here this big mushroom guy this
[ __ ] mushroom guy is the guy that
always helps you with the puzzles oh
look so happy yeah but he's only happy
when you whistle if you're not whistling
he's just grumpy and heads right hahaha
yeah yeah he's got a real real range of
emotion there yeah and now he is running
yeah because I refine yeah we painted
him green so he tries to run off but we
like coke on him so we can like run over
stuff run over enemies destroy obstacles
and cool stuff like this and now he's
angry storms you could like activate the
switch any yells and he's honestly I'm
charmed by that guy I feel like he's
really adorable despite the yelling and
the grumpiness I kind of want to hang
out with him yeah it's a cool guy I love
him too so who are the other characters
in the world that you are trying to
inspire so the city right now is divided
into three districts that's the red the
green and the blue district and each
other his own people and the green
district they're like kind of turtle
bunny rabbits kind of guys that always
scared of everything they're like a lot
of security system and you try to show
them that you hey I don't want to harm
you like guys we have to do something
together something cool uh-huh and the
blue district they're like so some fat
beers they're like every sober and in
the wrapper streak they are all about
anger and they like attack you for no
reason but they weren't like that all
the time so does it I do you ever have
your friends try this game out and then
they see themselves in it and you guys
kind of make it fun you got your angry
all the time friend right no alright so
sorry go ahead now the only thing we
made it in the game is like my hair kind
of what me that kind of is your hair I
mean you need a you need a bit of a dye
job for it but yeah it's so cute i love
ya the color the sort of the painterly
sort of created style do you guys work
any kind of creation elements into the
game that the player sort of has to take
on
actually not yet we what we plan on do
something like that mm-hmm but this was
more about like emotions and colors so
the like tinker and it s back just come
going to be in like the next things
we're gonna do with the game okay so how
you guys been working on this game for a
while I put a version of it out on steam
but you're still working on it still
developing yeah we improving it of
course for the ps4 like from the
feedback we have so these ps4 version
should be better by launch but we might
actually thinking about having like a
really cool special edition for the ps4
yeah maybe it's not on launch but a bit
later but there will be something cool
eat alright so this you know all right
about to ride a rainbow can and that's
wonderful yeah that's like a crazy dream
space we are right now in uh huh like
some time which has this whole damn open
a dream is this real life what's going
on realize its realize okay it's
happening this is happening right now
rainbow cannon projectors hey when you
go to other to other areas i mean this
one is up is green dominated because
it's the green color spirits realm I now
you've sort of made your way into a
wider area it's not just about restoring
color to the world like you said so
you're also bet your you know your sort
of vanquishing this whiteness year of
meeting up with the locals and trying to
help them out what other kind of regions
and other kind of spaces do you do you
get to go to for example in the blue
district there's this Admiral and he's
like super depressed because he is too
has to less power to define the
bleakness to save his people so you have
to help him and inspire him again to
inspire a soldier then so that's a thing
you doing that you've gotta motivate the
Admiral and now you've got a pound on
the uvula of this giant slug worm yeah
so right now you using like green in a
clever way because they're like those
forms and you have the enemies running
in the forms they're just running on the
doors n because they are frayed so
that's like actually the first time
where you learn the green power here in
this room mm-hmm and then that's just
the red power attack on the that that
creature over there I in the stream
right now you don't have the red power
okay you only have to do them for
example the blue how you you stun them
and it would just be there and cry oh
and you wouldn't have to deal with them
you could handle other enemies while
they just stand there and cry yeah but
they will be getting normal of this will
cheer up eventually and come after you
again yeah it's a lot of fun when you do
it with the NPC's you can just go nuts
and play with their feelings it's fun
yeah so they cry their phrase sangre
super emotionally manipulative yeah I
you guys have a lot of cute little
characters in this I kind of been
picturing your office just being filled
with stuffed animals and little plushies
you know actually that accurate and I
know but we have like some cod4 trees
like they are different from those one
we actually have in our office so I'm
kind of working in the forest yeah there
you go in a good inspiration for the
green levels especially yeah all right
you're backing back on it yeah terrified
much for men and just smash it through
everything here no that's a very cool
segment it's kind of like a highway
where you just run over stuff mm-hmm so
there would be some enemies um yeah you
have avoid those and you got these like
fans cheering and your these cardboard
fans cheering in the streams game I
imagine you mentioned before one of the
other sort of creative outlandish
situations you get into is conducting an
orchestra with color you guys obviously
the last tinker's are very creative
endeavor but you really sort of leaned
into it with these dreamscapes seems uh
yet a dream save
up here like three times in the game so
it's not like the not everywhere whole
bunch okay no because like usually we
don't show them that much just we want
to show them for you guys well we
appreciate it i mean this is it you know
this is a cool thing to discover and get
to get to see and get a taste for the
kind of jubilant aesthetic of the last
tinker and the kind of puzzles and stuff
you get involved with i just wish i
could see this guy's face hollering into
the whole time I can't move the camera
oh so it's fun I get pictured in my mind
and it's delightful Brendan there's like
enemies around him he's afraid anyways
so if you go like I think if you go off
them and just stand there you should be
afraid yeah that's so expressive I love
it I so the last tinker a single-player
adventure mostly and you know about how
long do you think would take a player to
complete it it's like an average of
eight hours and we really try to have no
like grinding in it it's like not a
hardcore game it's more like enjoying
get something new to experience all the
time mm-hmm do you guys have any
particular inspirations going into this
but I mean you mentioned the artists
those colorful European artists in terms
of the story that you wanted to tell
though what what sort of i've got you
going down this path it's a bit inspired
by the neverending story yeah but like
the lack of creativity and like of
people working together that's a thing
and there's like a topic of racism also
going up like dividing a city in two
different colored districts where
not allowed but it's like not in your
face but yeah it's just a one of the
sort of undercurrent of the game as well
under all we have like slow motion going
on here which is no cool ability you
will learn slow motion wait is that an
ability or that's just the way that it
sort of panned out no you're in the
cutscene know you will learn the ability
to slow down time oh that sounds good
all right so tagging each individual one
with green we're going to watch them
like all get massively terrified I'm
gonna go crazy in a second and now that
just run all off and what are these
little color balls that are coming your
way and also the common crystals is kind
of the currency in the game okay you can
like upgrade your combat moves you can
buy some extra help stuff like this can
you get a different color scarf like Oh
new hats no no it's not like that much
of customization you get some gear
during the game oh hey it's the little
aww it's a little red guy anger color
spirit is excited uh so he's a you're
you're about to escape the dream skata
exactly i don't back into the world yes
now we're gonna go back to the green
district know which looks like very
awesome like this the first hard we
showed was like the windmill that's kind
of a desolated island and this is more
like a vivid island where people are
living so that he looks cooler I think
so oh alright so this is this was not
sort of the area or exploring before
this is back in the the city proper yes
alright well let's take a quick look
around the city and then we'll sort of
wrap things up with the last tinker here
but is there anything anything else we
sort of haven't talked about her
explored here in the game that you guys
you guys find fun that you want to talk
about
like it you did these color spirits just
kind of follow you around are they
invested in your efforts or do they you
just kind of you're taking charge and
you're like helping them out because
they can't help themselves no actually
they are helping you so in the beginning
the red color spirit is actually calling
you he's the only guy that kind of knows
what's going on in this world and then
you have to find the other color spirits
and the cool thing is they grant you
their powers by going into inside your
body so there the whole time with you so
that's why they can like comment on
stuff so they can pop out and go forward
like no don't do it and for example
there's a father who is missing his son
and there's like a mini quest to earn
their trust right now so you have to
find the son that they will open a gate
for you is that Ram the blue color
spirit what no yeah so there were three
characters there there was the dad there
was a green color spirit and then there
was like a little ram ah this guy yeah
that's tab Oh actually we didn't talk
about him yet the absolute pity so he's
tap he's your best friend he's the whole
time with you also and he kind of does
the talking for you and the cool thing
is you also can help you by showing you
the way where you have to go so can you
call tap oh yeah okay so you always
liked flying where you kind of next
mission of Jace little confetti trail
and yeah he's booked use rockets right
out yeah like he can go through anywhere
tell me this much room guy's name again
he is Bombur bummer oh it's not that's a
different dude that ombre yeah but you
can change his physique city okay it is
like a weird plan that can make him pick
up small so he's bomba or pigs that dude
is my favorite by far yeah I love it's
also my favorite is so charming them the
solo game just kind of exudes this charm
and its delight are you sort of you know
hoping that people of all ages will
enjoy this game is it is it sort of
calibrated difficulty wise to be very
accessible no I think it we tried it to
have it like fairly accessible yeah so
it's more like some like really hardcore
players might find it too easy
you but I think if they just want to
enjoy it and they yeah they they will
enjoy for sure because you thought about
like mastering the last Inca it's like
enjoy the last tinker absolutely and
even if you've got a mean frown on your
face like that old fella so the last
tinker city of colors again it's
available now on steam and you guys are
also releasing it for the playstation 4
and they did some later this summer time
yeah all right and then maybe news on
other platforms to come is there a
website or something that people can get
information about it I'm yeah there's
our website that's mi mi mi minus
productions com all right though dare
you can hear everything about us and we
also on Facebook very cool well Dominic
mo thank you guys so much for coming on
and showing this a really charming
colorful delightful game to wrap up our
stage demos here at e3 thank you very
much and we would absolutely